she's the biggest pop star in the world
everyone it seems wants a piece of
Taylor Swift hey y'all it's Taylor Swift
here here She is selling cookware it
certainly sounds like her and explicit
photos that appeared online this week
look like her but none of it is real
it's AI generated deep fake and has
caught the eye of top officials we are
alarmed by uh the reports of the of the
circulation of images that you just laid
out false images to be more exact and it
is alarming the quality of deep pick
technology is advancing at an alarming
rate comedian George Carlin died in 2008
yet here he is I'm sorry it took me so
long to come out with new material but I
I do have a pretty good excuse I was
dead while his estate is suing the media
company that created it finding who is
responsible for the President Joe Biden
robocall ACH of won't be as easy partly
due to the anonymity of the internet but
also because there are only a handful of
US states that have laws related to AI
in Place Canada will be able to regulate
AI platforms with Bill c27 but it's
unlikely to be in place before next year
leaving the owners on the companies that
create the programs to build safeguards
that is a hail as oldest time of
capitalism right of the it is really an
arms race right now between Microsoft
Google um uh you know Amazon the big
tech companies uh to try to create the
market share around this technology um
and the result is that they're cutting
corers on uh what I would call sponsible
development or or ethical development
but tech companies and governments alike
will have a hard time ignoring Tay's
rabbit fan base which reacted swiftly to
purge social media of the offens of
photos which in turn prompted Microsoft
CEO to promise action I think that it's
behooves us to move fast on this it's a
Brave New World out there when it comes
to technology we just have to decide
what we want that world to look like
Mike trle Global News
Toronto